you've announced that you're leaving  Grays it's been a century  it's the longest running show how do you  feel is was it was it are you ready is  it time do you have a next game plan are  you ready to not know what is what is it  I feel super happy really  yeah  um but listen the show has been  incredible to me and and I love I've  loved  a lot of the experience listen it's just  I gotta you know I gotta mix it up a  little bit I'm 53 my brain is like  scrambled eggs God you're hot I have to  thank you I gotta do some new I gotta do  something new or I'm gonna literally  turn into like you know you can't choose  a New York Times crossword puzzle every  single day I mean 19 years is like more  that's longer than people keep their  kids in their house like people keep  their kids in their house until they're  18 and then they send them off to  college so this is like me like going  away to college kind of